security minister is with us now damian
hines of course want to ask you about
liverpool and what happened what on
earth has happened there but first quick
thought on um the allegations against um
stanley johnson from caroline knox how
will the party be investigating those
allegations
so okay i just don't know the details of
the um of the allegation that um the
talking about that we've just been that
we've just been hearing about and
what i can say is that yeah overall in
terms of
any harassment of women and broader
violence against women and girls there's
an absolute priority for government i'm
not linking that to what's just been
said you'll understand i'm not in a
position to to to be able to comment but
we do take extremely seriously um these
issues but i'm sure what you can say is
that no matter how far back an
allegation goes um if it was as part of
a tory party conference or an event that
was organized by the conservative party
you will investigate that surely so i'm
genuinely not in a position to be able
to give you more information than than
than what you have if there are
investigations to be had then of course
they will of course they will take place
i can't i can't speak to the detail of
of the allegation or the circumstance
because i just don't know and i've just
heard i've just been hearing this this
morning okay um i'm sure we'll hear more
about it during the course of the day
talk to me about what's happened
in liverpool how was this attacker
able to make an explosive device
well these are matters of course that
the police are looking into the
investigation is moving
is moving at pace you'll have heard the
statement from northwest county
terrorism police that you know they were
discovering more by the hour but
nevertheless it can take quite some time
could be weeks before the absolutely
full picture is known of
how this came about um
yeah what the motivation was uh if
potentially other people were involved
and and so on so we need to leave space
and time
for the police to to do their work and
my thoughts and yours i know and all
viewers thoughts would be with the
the people of liverpool this has been a
uh absolutely terrible event very
upsetting unsettling uh for many i know
the police in merseyside have been uh
putting on extra uh reassurance
visibility uh on the streets and as i
say our thoughts are very much with the
people of the city and and everybody
affected by this incident okay let me
put it another way how concerned are we
about lone wolves that during the
pandemic have managed to be in their
bedrooms tapping away on their computers
and being radicalized
you should be concerned of course so i
mean we use the term lone wolf a lot
sometimes it's it's a bit it can be a
little a little misleading because it
gives a certain picture
of of an individual but it certainly is
true that we've seen a move over time a
shift from
these sort of
what we call directed attacks you know
part of a bigger organization where
people are following
uh instruction sometimes quite complex
in their organization and move from that
to more self-directed some
self-radicalized
individuals or or small groups rarely
totally totally alone because people
talk to one another they take advice
they give hints
but yes there has been that move and you
mentioned lockdown of course uh during
the lockdown periods there have been
more people spending more time in front
of computer screens and we know that
when that happens for a very small
minority very very small minority of
people but there can be um
radicalization with with very very bad
so it's something that we've been aware
of
that that's happened that people are
being radicalized as a result of of uh
so i'm afraid it's not it's not brand
new okay i mean
radicalization self-radicalization but
that's on the internet the the
propaganda the way that people make
contact with one another and so on that
that is not a new development but but
like like a number of things
the trends that we saw through through
the coronavirus period through through
lockdown um they have changed modus
operandi and in this case yes they will
have exacerbated increase the amount of
time that that people are spending um
online and for some that that means very
very badly so if we were aware of that
why then in february did at the very
height of the pandemic did we reduce the
alert level
so
the alert level is determined
independently of ministers it's not
something i determine or the home
secretary determines we have a body
uh jtac the joint terrorism analysis
center who are experts in this area and
they use the alert
level it's a way that
law enforcement security services and
others
can can calibrate
uh what they are doing the protective
security measures that are needed but
look we've been at a high alert for a
very long time now
and that that's the important thing you
know we need people to be we talk about
alert but but not alarmed we need people
to be vigilant if people see something
uh suspicious something that isn't right
uh to report and of course in this
particular incident anybody who has any
information pleased to come forward
either directly to north west police or
we can always call crime stoppers
anonymously indeed so i understand that
minister but you know if we were aware
um or the security services were aware
that at the height of a pandemic would
mean that more lone wolves whatever you
want to call them pathetic thugs who
want to kill women in hospital or people
who were at a remembrance service if we
knew that potentially there were more of
them because of the pandemic why would
we reduce the alert level so the alert
level was
substantial meaning an attack was likely
and and and we reached that no no no
that that that that was it we reduced it
to that yeah yes that that was it
and there are different calibrations um
depending on particular intelligence
available
at the time and as i say these are ways
that
the public agencies the law enforcement
bodies that keep us safe can can help to
calibrate
their response and what they do but the
alert has been high for a very long
period of time and whenever the alert is
is high it means that these things i'm
afraid uh sadly tragically um can happen
and and of course as we have seen
periodically do given what we saw in
liverpool at the weekend was that the
right decision
was what the right decision that we
reduced through the alert level well as
i said these these are not decisions
that i make or ministers
they we entrust professionals
experts in the field what's your opinion
my opinion is i absolutely trust them to
make those to make those correct
judgments and can i also just say okay i
mean you know in my position i i have
the privilege of
seeing working with hearing from um the
amazing people who work in our in our
security services uh and in and in law
enforcement keeping us safe they are
working night and day
to protect us um from attacks and and
although an instance such as this one is
uh appalling absolutely awful um
there are also
multiple times when we are protected
from this there have been over 30
uh late stage plot disruptions in the
last in the last few years okay given
that you said that you wouldn't call him
a lone wolf what would you call him
i i didn't say that and in fact if i
would say one thing it's that i can't um
i can't comment on the detail of this
case at all for reasons you'll
understand yes
it's a but
it is a live investigation uh and it's
very very important that the police
uh have these actually
have the investigation whether you what
your viewers of this matter how have
they have the space to be able to um to
be able to to do the investigation yes a
long time since i read my central law
for journalists but i know that your
comments about what you think about this
guy is not going to impact on the
investigation it is look it is a live
investigation there's always the
possibility that there
may be other people um involved we don't
know that the police has already
if that is the case
uh then then obviously they'll respond
uh appropriate and arrests made um if uh
if necessary what do you think of the uh
what do you think of the taxi driver i'm
not
okay please please understand and i
think you do that i'm not in a position
you can comment on the bravery of the
taxi driver i comment on on the details
of the case what i can say is
thank god mr perry is out of hospital um
thank god others were not uh were not
injured or killed we can be very very
extremely grateful for that
in the case in his case mr perry's case
i mean he's been through a
a terrible terrible trauma and i think
it's important also that he has uh
afforded
privacy to to to deal with the party was
very happy yesterday to say that he um
he thought his bravery went out of uh
you know was above and beyond what you
would expect and and okay look we're all
of course um immensely
pleased and grateful um
uh as i say that that that he he is now
out of hospital that that is a wonderful
thing we are
pleased and grateful that others were
not were not hurt the exact sequence of
uh what what has happened has to be
something that the has to be something
that the police invest again come
forward with over time okay i wasn't
necessarily asking about that but okay
hs2 um it's part of it's going to be
scrapped what reaction can you
reasonably expect i suppose uh from the
people in the north who you promised so
much to at the last election
so as my understanding is not you'll
understand obviously transport is not my
department but i understand the
integrated rail review comes out later
this week and only when that comes out
do we know do we know what's in it
uh i think we know before that that part
because not least because uh we've heard
from labor we've also heard uh from the
um the um uh uh
ministers is not the word i'm looking
for mayors of of the towns involved who
are all saying that uh you know it's an
absolute betrayal that you are scrapping
that leg of hs2 that goes up to lead
so i i am not aware of that because the
the because the integrated you know the
integrated real review i don't believe
you is due out but not this morning it's
coming it's coming later this week and
when it comes we'll be able to well it
won't be me on your show that day but
you'll be able to talk to somebody
sitting in this seat about it well it's
our understanding
what's your view what do you think that
people up in the north will think when
they will promise the earth for their
votes and it looks as though that's not
going to happen i think we're very
leveling up because i think we're
absolutely committed to leveling up i
think that is runs through it is infused
in something you don't want to get on a
fast train in everything government does
transport also is part of that and so uh
and so many other things on the
specifics of the railways we're gonna
have to wait for the integrated rail
review okay well we do know what's going
to happen as far as covid and boosters
are concerned because the prime minister
was talking about it yesterday and it
does look as though you're going to have
to have your booster in order to be able
to travel overseas
so we want people to
to get their boosters um you know the
the vaccination program as you know has
been a
has been enormously important and
enormously successful it helps to keep
us
helps to keep us all safe we're inching
back
towards uh towards normality i think
that's a good thing i think it's what
people it's what people welcome so my
encouragement to everybody is when you
get the invitation
to get the uh to get the booster to go
ahead and do it
not as successful as you would want it
to be you were aiming for half a million
people a day being vaccinated it was
only 250 000 yesterday
so i haven't looked at the counter for
yesterday okay
i always i always trust thank you you
should
but but
i think you're making my point for me
well i'm not because i'm saying actually
i think i'm doing exactly the opposite
which is you said half a million people
a day were going to get their boost just
250 000 and if you don't have your
booster the um suggestion is that you
won't be able to go on your holidays
well when i say you make him a point for
me what i mean is we want people to get
there to get the booster jab and that is
yeah you're blackmailing this i'm not
blackmailing anybody i'm saying
government
it's good for it and it is it's good for
all of us
it's good for us as individuals it's
good for us as a as a society and this
is how we are you know with the
vaccination this has been how we've been
able to to start to move out of this
what's been a very very difficult period
for so many people a tragic period for
for those who've lost who've lost loved
ones and the the booster jab is is the
very important next stage okay good to
talk to you thank you thank you for
joining us much appreciated thank you